as an architect who specializes in
high-end residential homes I often find
myself with Incredible Furniture budgets
however at the same time I sometimes
find myself scratching my head thinking
how is this furniture budget even
possible in this scenario I find Ika
might just be the best solution for us
today I'm sharing my top 12 Ikea
products that will make any home on any
budget but I'm also sharing with you my
top 16 Ikea products that you must avoid
now let's get started with sofas and by
me absolutely butchering these Swedish
words I actually have a Swedish
sister-in-law and I really should have
asked her how to pronounce these not to
make complete fool myself but we're
going to start with the glow stad the
glow stad is one of my do not buy items
on this list it is just a cheap and
nasty sofa it is uncomfortable it isn't
practical and it is just trying to be
high-end but it's falling short on every
account if you look at the legs they
have no shape they have no depth they
have no profile if you look at the
fabric it is falling off the actual sofa
before you've taken it home this product
is just not okay even if they're only
looking for $199 Australian do along
with their glow stad the EG toop is
another noo the egg toop is basically an
old school sofa that people have draped
some very cheap nasty Fabrics over them
and made them look somewhat reasonable
the fact that this sofa looks relatively
used before you even buy it should not
be in anybody's home even if you're a
student looking to furnish their dorm
this is not something you should be
steering towards on the other hand if
you have a little bit more of a budget
the Apple laide completely butchered it
is the go-to sofa from Ikea first of all
those iconic linear lines and the slim
profiles that they were trying to
achieve in the glow dad have actually
been achieved here I won't even try to
pronounce this name again but this sof
far actually achieves high-end
residential Furniture quite well
generally from my experience it is quite
comfortable to sit on even for long
periods of time so this product will set
you back a good $2,000 Australian but at
the same time it will actually be able
to be placed in any home in any Budget
moving on to TV cabinets and I have a
few gripes here there is three that I'm
going to steer clear of completely and I
recommend you avoid them as well first
of all the lack is just a cheap and
nasty University student product we
actually had this during University and
it was terrible I remember walking into
what is now my wife's home back in the
day and thinking this is the cheapest
nastiest table I've ever seen in my life
why would anybody own this now the Lac
is obviously a very cheap product you
can pick it up for next to nothing but
at the same time it probably should be
nothing and you should leave it alone
the baggy B aligns in this same category
even though it looks like a nice product
it looks like it's trying to innovate
through industrial design White Modern
Sleek it is going to be a dust collector
this thing is perforated and has mesh
panels that just don't go anywhere steel
tube legs with plastic cappings none of
which align with the industrial f it
hasn't been thought out it isn't
minimalist and it's just a product
trying to attack a market that it
shouldn't be in the same principle
applies to the FL bow completely
butchering it again this product again
perforated mesh panels all around
industrial look it is trying to achieve
something that it just can't achieve the
Timber Top above is not meeting the
designer Aesthetics it is basically
looking like an extremely cheap cabinet
that you were able to pick up from Kmart
or Target but you've gone out and spent
$250 Australian dollar for a product
that just isn't worth the price it's
going to collect dust all of your cables
are going to show and it just isn't the
product for a nice elegant home Ika does
have have some nice TV cabinets however
and I'm not just going to talk about
them all the besta for example is a
phenomenal product I've owned the besta
cabinet for almost a decade now there's
a couple things I'd recommend with the
besta first of all make sure that all of
the holes are covered up if you can
avoid it don't leave any of the gaps
open they just collect dust and even
though your TV remote may need to be
able to get to a DVD player if you're
old school you don't really use them
that often so if you can cover them with
a door go for for it and second of all
try to avoid having legs on these
products if you put legs on them they
tend to collapse under their own weight
over time so what I would suggest is
chop off the legs don't put them on save
yourself a few dollars and either Mount
them to the wall or lift them ever so
slightly so the doors can open over your
carpets with ease finally if you're
willing to spend $550 on a TV cabinet
that looks nice the stockh home is
probably one of Ikea's best products now
at the same time there are are a few
flaws that you have to be aware of
obviously this is a veneer product and
the wood grains Go in all directions now
this is intentional to create a chaotic
pattern it is something that is going to
establish the TV unit as a statement
piece in your space now personally I
don't like the statement piece being the
TV cabinet I'd much rather it be a piece
of furniture the armchair or the rug
however if you are looking for a
statement piece in the TV cabinet
specifically this might just be the way
to go moving on to office chairs because
they are one of the most critical
elements in any home first of all the
home office is getting so much more use
than it ever did and office chairs are
so important to get right if your office
chair is uncomfortable you're going to
hate working in it so we want to pick
the best one AIA has some good ones but
they have some terrible ones as well
starting with the renberget just just
don't I don't need to tell you too much
just just don't next we have the alfal
which has to be the most uncomfortable
chair I've ever sat in my life I
actually went and tested this chair
thinking it would be high quality and it
would be something that you could
actually work in for a prolong period of
time I didn't last 4 seconds in this
chair before I got up and went
absolutely no way am I spending a single
Dollar on it so personally I would stay
away from that chair as well if you work
prolonged periods of time if you're
looking for a chair that just looks good
in the space this is the one it looks
phenomenal but it just isn't comfortable
at all on the other hand the Lang FAL is
a very very comfortable chair we have
these in our board room as general
chairs and they're incredibly
comfortable to sit on for a prong period
of time they can actually double as a
dining chair if you don't want to put
the wheels on them to make them office
chairs so personally I think they come
in great colors they suit the Aesthetics
of most spaces and they're incredibly
comfortable to sit on long term if
you're looking for something more
ergonomical and something that can sit
in for a much longer period of time I'm
going to try read this one out because
I'm going to butcher it completely it is
the jar View
that not even close anyway this chair on
the screen right now is super
comfortable we have them in our office
and I've been using it for a good 2 and
1/2 years now they're no longer
producing the fabric ones it's just the
leather version but they are still super
super comfortable for prolong periods of
time and they just look kind of like a
spaceship alien combined futuristic
style something that is a conversation
piece and works really well as an
ergonomic chair beds from Ikea is
something that I considered for a very
very long long time as a university
student and went and looked at them time
and time again but what I found is the
price are paying for even some of their
cheapest beds you can find so many
better options for example the Trava
frame bed is
$250 I can easily go on eBay right now
and find hundreds of options for Less
that are significantly better the same
goes for the mandal it looks like a
pallet has been stacked together and a
bit of gloss paint has been put on it
yes there's some nice drawers underneath
the storage but but it's just not an
appealing bed it genuinely looks like
pallets it should be in nobody's
architectural home even if you're going
full industrial trying to design
something a pallet bed would look better
in the space than this bed here what is
an acceptable option is something like
the tough yorg this bed has modern Sleek
elegant design features it has
wraparound curves on the Bed Head and it
comes in two very prominent colors now
beds often in master suites and primary
SU
are designed to stand out they are
designed to be special so picking a nice
colored bed picking something that
stands out is exactly what you want to
be looking for in the mirrors category
there is literally just one series of
mirrors you have to look at don't worry
about any of them else just look at the
lindan this right here on the screen
search that Nika pick any of their
actual mirrors and it is an incredibly
well-built sturdy solid mirror you can
go for the Spheres the overalls the pill
shapes all of them are really really
good try to avoid the cheap nasty desk
mirror that's just a one-off outlier but
the rest are phenomenal moving on to
dining chairs now dining chairs are an
extremely hard buy first of all dining
chairs are so expensive doesn't matter
what shop you go into you're going to be
paying a couple hundred for a good
dining chair but what you want to avoid
when you go to IKEA is picking a dining
chair that looks like your grandmother's
if it looks like your grandmother's it's
probably not going to work well in a
nice architectural modern home so
something like the eadan which is $99 a
chair may look relatively comfortable
it's got some cushioning and it's
generally solid wood it is definitely
something you'll find at your
grandmother's house so stay clear just
from an architectural styling
perspective on the extreme other end you
have the kryb this chair might look
extremely architectural it might look
extremely stylish but it is extremely
uncomfortable it is not something you're
going to enjoy sitting in having a nice
meal and it may be a conversation with
starter during dinner up but it's going
to be oh this chair is an uncomfortable
one why' you buy it rather than oh these
chairs are fantastic I love them in
reality they're probably going to be
just as uncomfortable as me sitting on
this desk right now Ika does have one
great dining chair and that is the
tossberg this dining chair is a little
bit more oversized it's a little bit
more formal but at the same time it is
going to make a statement it's
comfortable it's the right color palette
now $249 Australian for this chair might
seem excessive but if you compare the
chair to any other brand any other
Market you'll be paying $750,000 a chair
for something that looks like this
moving on to armchairs there's one
armchair that has just been completely
overdone and people are trying to
reimagine it as much as they can the
havburg from Ikea is just a complete
ripoff from the EMS chair the EMS chair
has been pictured in some of the best
architecture around the world and it has
been for decades because it is such an
iconic chair this on the other hand is
trying to be a complete ripoff using
using the same two-piece concept but not
even hitting the mark there's a reason
the E chair was so popular and I use the
word so because that chair is now well
and gone instead you want to be looking
at Brands like yti something out of
Italy that is custom made and really
dominate The Market at the moment if you
look at guetti you'll find some
incredible arm chairs which Ika has
actually found some design inspiration
from if we look at the echan asset it is
a chair that is relatively architectural
and modern and contemporary it is a
simple two-tone classic color wood and
fabric it is something that can almost
blend in to any space and any
architectural style at
$349 it is not an excessive piece for an
armchair that is a feature in your room
if you are looking for that e armchair
look I've been more Swain towards the
aliy it's a bit more of a modern
interpretation of the look going all
fabric all classic still a simple
monochromatic color scheme but using a
two-tone palette to Define shapes sizes
depths as well so if you are looking for
it something like this might be a little
bit of a better option but I still
probably wouldn't lean too heavily
towards it last but not least we have
our coffee tables and of course the lack
makes another appearance on this list
the lack coffee table is nasty just just
don't seriously just don't not even
worth talking about the dalion is
another example of where Ikea is trying
to push into a market that they just
missed the mark this perforated mesh
trolley is something that's trying to be
architectural trying to meet that upper
End Market but it kind of looks like
something you'd find in your toddler
playroom it is not overly stylish it is
not overly elegant it just looks
childish however something like the fro
top could be an incredible coffee table
it incorporates the marble Elegance on
the lower section of the coffee table so
you aren't making visual contact
noticing it isn't marble whilst also
removing those highend finishes and
sticking to something more contemporary
like a black flat surface on top that
you know may look a little bit cheaper
but it isn't trying to be fake anyway
that's all for me team thank you so much
for watching if you enjoyed the video
make sure you smash that subscribe
button down below aiming to reach to
100,000 subscribers by the end of the
year an impossible goal that will only
be reached with your help like always I
appreciate all of you and I'll see you
next week